Estonia es ese país al que solo
escuchas mencionar en el Festival de
Eurovisión, y eso si eres ese tipo de
persona que ve los Festivales de
Eurovisión.
Lo cierto es que Estonia es un país
pionero en muchas cosas, es más, lo
podríamos calificar como el Silicon
Valley europeo. Empresas como Skype han
nacido en este país con sólo un
millón de habitantes y todo esto pese a
que hace 30 años formaban parte de la
unión soviética. No sólo eso, Estonia
tiene una situación de partida bastante
puñetera su clima es asqueroso en
invierno solamente tienen tres horas de
luz al día. Además, Estonia tiene una
crisis demográfica perpetua y muy
difícil de resolver porque es uno de
los pocos países donde hay muchísima
más población femenina que población
masculina. Es muy difícil que la gente
se pueda emparejar y pueda hacer bebes,
con lo cual están continuamente
perdiendo población y pese a todo esto
Estonia es el país más moderno de
Europa, es el único lugar del mundo
donde el acceso a internet está
garantizado como un derecho por la
Constitución. Pero, lo que hace que este
país entre en nuestro salón de la fama
de los países, es la llamada residencia virtual, es decir, cualquier
persona del mundo independientemente de
dónde esté
puedes solicitar un permiso de
residencia y convertirse en ciudadano
virtual de Estonia y ¿qué significa
esto? os preguntareis. En en este video lo
vamos a explicar pero antes vamos a
daros un poquito de trasfondo histórico
de este país donde las cosas nunca han
sido fáciles.
- "Víctimas de Vladimir Putin en 1991"
Estonia se independizó de la Unión
Soviética, también lo hicieron otros
países como Ucrania o Bielorrusia, pero
en realidad no fue una independencia
real porque los nuevos gobiernos
democráticos mantenían todas las
jerarquías ya todas las autoridades del
antiguo partido comunista. No fue así en
Estonia. Su primer presidente después de
la independencia,
Mart Laar, creó un gabinete de
ministros con una media de edad de 30
años y que no le debía absolutamente
nada a los antiguos gerifaltes
soviéticos.
Así es como Estonia se abrió
rápidamente al mercado internacional y
sin apenas corrupción. No sólo
modernizaron su economía sino que,
además, implementaron un sistema de
administración pública que es único
en el mundo por lo minimalista que puede
llegar a ser.
De hecho, esa es la palabra que define a
Estonia: minimalismo. Lo podemos ver hasta
en su bandera que si os dais cuenta es
la representación simplificada de su
paisaje tradicional.
Sin embargo, no era suficiente. A
principios de los 90 sólo la mitad de
la población estonia tenía una línea
telefónica en casa. A falta de dinero
para carreteras decidieron invertir todo
lo que tenían en telecomunicaciones. 15
años más tarde
Estonia se convertía en el primer
país donde se votaba online.
Sin embargo, todas estas reformas no
salieron gratis durante estos 15 años
de progreso la minoría rusa que antes
dominaba la política estonia se había
quedado aislada, por eso en el año 2007
el Kremlin ya con Vladimir Putin
gobernando, organiza el primer ciberataque de la historia mundial contra el
gobierno de Estonia, que como os hemos
dicho estaba ya completamente
digitalizado.
Así que, durante días este país se
quedó totalmente sin gobierno, ni
siquiera los hospitales podían
funcionar. Desde entonces la OTAN tiene
su centro de protección contra
ciberataques en Tallin, que, para quien no
lo sepa, es la capital de Estonia.
Sin embargo los problemas de Estonia no
terminaron aquí.
- "La crisis financiera." Dos años más
tarde, en 2009, la crisis financiera
mundial golpeó especialmente a Estonia
que estaba especialmente expuesta a las
inversiones internacionales.
Así que, el gobierno se encontró con
que de golpe y porrazo no tenía dinero
y además estaban a puntito de entrar en
la eurozona: sólo tenían dos opciones o
subían los impuestos o recortaban
gastos. En sólo unos meses
Estonia despidió a 10.000 funcionarios,
lo que suponía la tercera parte de la
plantilla pública. Por supuesto los
políticos se bajarán el sueldo y se
paralizaron todas las inversiones del
gobierno.
Lo cierto es que todos estos recortes
llevaron a que el PIB de Estonia
cayera un 14 por ciento ese año. Para
que os hagais una idea, el de España en
su peor momento sólo llegó a caer un
3,6.
Sin embargo, después de pasar este 2009
tan horrible, la economía estonia
empezó a recuperarse inmediatamente.
Como no habían subido los impuestos y
montar negocios era algo muy sencillo,
muchos de las que se habían quedado en
el paro comenzarán a montar sus propias
empresas.
De hecho, aquí podemos ver el
gráfico del desempleo: en sólo un año
Estonia pasó de un 4% de paro
a un 19%.
Sin embargo, en sólo dos años
consiguieron reducirlo a la mitad.
Algo parecido ocurrió con los sueldos y
de hecho hoy en día alguien que está
trabajando en Tallin gana más dinero que
alguien que está trabajando en Sevilla
y, además, encuentra trabajo más
fácilmente. En una palabra,
Estonia es un ejemplo a tener en cuenta.
Pero vamos a ver dos de los aspectos
clave que han catapultado este éxito. - "Administración digital." Estonia fue
pionera en la creación del dni
electrónico.
Muchos países han intentado seguir este
modelo pero no ha llegado a funcionar
del todo bien,
tal vez sea porque en estonia el dni
electrónico realmente tiene una
utilidad, por ejemplo, se puede utilizar
para votar.
Esto nos lo va a explicar mi buen amigo
David Miguel Gaite, que es un
arquitecto español que vive en Estonia. - "Cualquier
persona con tal de disponer de un dni
electrónico y una conexión a internet,
sin ningún tipo de gestión previa,
puede hacerlo en cuestión de segundos
desde cualquier parte del mundo." Pero no sólo eso,
es que el dni electrónico
también te sirve para pedir cita al
médico o incluso a para pagar los
impuestos -"Presentar la declaración
de la renta
es un proceso bastante sencillo que
se hace en cuestión de minutos también porque
parte del sistema fiscal estonio
está bastante simplificado y por otra
parte pues tienes el 99% de los datos
necesarios automáticamente incluidos."
Esperad que aquí llega lo bueno, porque
alguno dirá, bueno está muy bien esto del
gobierno electrónico pero puede suponer
una violación de mi privacidad.
Por ejemplo, imaginemos que alguien de la
administración
quisiera fisgar nuestros datos, pues bien
desde vuestro propio panel de control en
la página web del gobierno estonio
podéis ver exactamente quién está
mirando vuestros datos, en qué momento
y para qué.
Y podéis exigir una explicación
oficial. Por si todo esto fuera
poco, aquí llega lo que hace que Estonia
entre de lleno en nuestro sunset
boulevard de los países.
- "La residencia de ciudadanía virtual." Todos
hemos oído hablar de grandes empresas
que establecen su sede fiscal en Panamá o en Luxemburgo,
sin embargo, todo este tipo de
movimientos son prácticamente
imposibles si eres un autónomo o una
pyme - "Vivo en Luxemburgo
y si quieres abrir una empresa en
luxemburgo
primero tienes que ir al notario y para
el notario tienes que esperar tres
semanas para conseguir una cita, y luego
tienes  que pagar un montón de dinero y
hay un montón de burocracia."
Pues bien, en Estonia se dieron cuenta de
que necesitaban ciudadanos nuevos, así
que, en el año 2014 decidieron ofrecer
todos estos servicios de Administración
Pública digital a cualquier persona del
mundo, sin importar en qué parte del
planeta esté. Y os preguntareis ¿para
qué sirve todo esto? Por supuesto que no
es el equivalente a un visado de
ciudadanía, ni tampoco a un pasaporte.
Lo que sí que te permite, por ejemplo, es
abrirte una cuenta en un banco estonio y
poder hacer transferencias
internacionales.
Estoy seguro de que los que veáis este
vídeo desde Venezuela
entenderéis lo útil que puedan ser
estas cosas, y es que desde muchos
países es prácticamente imposible
hacer transferencias internacionales,
bien porque es ilegal o bien porque los
bancos no saben cómo hacerlo.
Pero es que, además, esta tarjeta de residencia virtual te
permite poder montar una empresa en
Estonia, sin necesidad de papeleos ni notarios. Y ya se lo que estáis pensando
alguno:
Estonia es un paraíso fiscal, ¿verdad?
¡Pues no! Resulta que el Impuesto de
Sociedades en Estonia es de un 20 por
ciento, que es bastante normal. De hecho,
es el mismo que tienen en Finlandia, por
ejemplo. Lo que Estonia te ofrece son
solamente dos cosas: seguridad jurídica
y papeleos simples ¿os parece poco? Pues
ya llevan diez mil nuevos ciudadanos
virtuales, en sólo dos años. Entre ellos,
destacan personalidades como el
Presidente de Japón, Shinzō Abe
En otras palabras,
Estonia ha inventado lo que podríamos
llamar la ciudadanía líquida, que cada
uno pueda ser del país que quiera.
La pregunta es ¿Creeis que otros
países haran algo parecido? ¿Llegará el
día en el que podamos elegir nuestra
nacionalidad?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. Si alguien quiere
profundizar más en este tema
encontrará varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y suscribiros al canal
que, como dice Alberto, es gratis.